saussines je maîtrise shadoks reposer
sur un postulat assez bizarre qui disait
moi la ligne droite est le plus long
chemin d'un point à un autre et vous
conviendrez que pour les voyages
interstellaires ça risquait de poser des
difficultés mais grâce à shen locaux
tout cela ait changé
écoutons la première dame le chou
définition le point est la plus courte
distance possible entre deux villes
première application étant données de
l'ign quelconque trouver l'endroit où
elle se coupe
supposons qu'elle se rend compte en zoé
me par exemple si l'on est ainsi d'après
notre définition la ligne zoho me serais
un point et serait plus courte que le
point de vue or ce n'est pas le cas donc
les lignes se rencontrent en bus d'où
théorème deux lignes qui se rencontrent
se rencontrent toujours au même endroit
propriétés remarquables tout ligne prise
lors d'un point ne passe pas par ce
point ou alors si elle y passe c'est
vraiment par hasard
deuxièmement les points parallèle on dit
qu'un point est parallèle à deux autres
points lorsque ce point est en
comptablement disposer si on le déplace
d'un côté ou de l'autre
il est plus parallèle d'où théorème la
condition suffisante pour qu'un point
reste bien parallèles à deux autres
points et qu'il reste là où il est et
qu'il ne bouge pas